you are taking a risk by coming to the  united states  he's also taking a risk  and i'm just want to make sure that  you're both  are aware of that you know yeah  a tiffany  all relationships will have problems  it's difficult to explain oh my gosh  in brazil he was  very us like different he  um  here he like changed  i just don't want him going through  the heartache and the divorce again no i  don't want  to get married and  get divorced is horrible  are you ready yes let's go  we'll be back all right come on over  here second on the right uh-huh  dress number one  edgy face  look at that it's beautiful what do you  think how do you feel  i think you need to try like  marzipan  you see  one  wow  look at the fit on this  it's like it was made for you  yeah  okay  do you love this dress yes yeah  can you see yourself getting married in  this dress  yes  [Music]  a  [Music]  you